this is Sara threats Turner sorry and
calm and in this video I'm going to be
going over sublingual nitroglycerin and
the oral spray and I'm going to show you
how to administer it now remember
whenever you administer nitroglycerin
you always want to follow your hospital
protocols for this medication along with
the manufacturer's instructions and
always be sure you have the proper
credentials when administering this
medication and for this video we are
using demo dose doses of nitroglycerin
so it's a simulated dose and these do
not really contain nitroglycerin so what
does nitroglycerin use for it's used to
relieve or treat chest pain and
nitroglycerin is part of the nitrate
family and because of this what it does
is it causes vasodilation on those blood
vessels so you have a patient they're
having chest pain they're getting
limited amount of blood to that heart
muscle and what nitroglycerin will do
open up those vessels and increase the
blood supply to that heart tissue along
with decreasing its workload so as a
nurse what do you expect to see in your
patient after you give them this drug
well you can expect to see facial
flushing from where they're getting
increased blood flow through the body
from that vasodilation they can also
experience like a burning or tingling
sensation underneath the tongue whenever
you give this sublingual the tablets you
will put underneath the tongue and the
spray you will spray under the tongue as
well also it can cause a very painful
headache from all the extra blood flow
they can experience dizziness and
definitely hypotension it's going to
lower the blood pressure so when your
patient is having chest pain as the
nurse of course you want to notify the
physician and a lot of hospitals already
have standing orders there for you to
follow out they're usually called chest
pain protocols and you will have this
order set that you need to do for your
patient which will include you know
giving the nitroglycerin possibly
morphine if the Nitro is not really
helping along with oxygen administer
via nasal canula of 20 obtaining a
12-lead EKG and drawing cardiac enzymes
so before you administer a nitroglycerin
to your patient of course you want to
confirm that they are not allergic to it
and that they haven't recently taken a
phosphodiesterase inhibitor like sadena
fill which is viagra or $2.00 fill which
is cialis because this can lead to
severe hypotension and possibly even
death and of course you don't want to
give this to a patient who has increased
intracranial pressure then you'll want
to perform hand hygiene perform the
patient's 5 right and whenever handling
nitroglycerin you want to wear gloves
because if you get this on yourself
you can give yourself some nitroglycerin
and you can get some of the side effects
that come along with this drug so first
let's talk about sublingual
nitroglycerin okay it comes in a dark
vial and this vial is dark for a reason
because nitroglycerin is very sensitive
and it doesn't need to come into contact
with white or heat or moisture and it's
only good for three months when the
bottle is opened and then you're gonna
have the patient sat down before
administering this to them because
remember it can cause dizziness and
hypotension and you want to obtain
baseline vital signs especially blood
pressure because you're gonna see a
decrease in their blood pressure and you
want to confirm that their systolic
blood pressure is within parameters and
most Hospital protocols require that
that's a solid blood pressure that top
number is greater than 90 and if it's
not and your patients having chest pain
you need to contact the physician for
further orders and preferably you want
them on a cardiac monitor so you can be
monitoring that rhythm looking at the ST
segment for normalities like St
elevation or depression to administer
you will place one tablet under the
tongue so how the patient lifts the
tongue up and it will dissolve under
there the patient does not need to chew
it or swallow it
and not to rinse the mouth because they
may feel like they need to do that
whenever they have the tablet under the
time because of the tingling sensation
and it's going to absorb within that
lining there and after giving the tablet
you'll want to make sure that you're
constantly monitoring their blood
pressure especially that's systolic
making sure it's greater then 90 and
their chest pain how is it rated is it
increasing is it decreasing is it going
away and if their systolic blood
pressure is still within parameters and
they're still having chest pain you can
do a second dose within five minutes
again monitoring that blood pressure and
their chest pain and the chest pain is
still there you can give a third dose
within five minutes now you do not want
to get more than three doses and if the
chest pain is still not relieved after
the third dose you'll want to notify the
physician now with the oral
nitroglycerin spray what you want to do
is of course remove the cap on the
bottle and if this is a new bottle
you'll want to prime it and a lot of
times in the hospital setting and you're
going to be using a new bottle of
nitroglycerin and to prime it you're
going to press the button to spray about
five to eight times just to get that
line in there nice and primed and
whenever you do that tip keep it away
from your face and other people's faces
you don't want to inhale this so we're
gonna probably about five to eight times
all right okay and then it's ready to
use and another tip with this spray is
that you don't want to shake the bottle
up and down remember nitroglycerin is
very sensitive and it's in a dark bottle
so keep it away from heat and light and
keep it in the upright position at all
times you don't want to store it
upside-down and to give the world
nitroglycerin spray you're gonna give
one spray underneath the tongue and tell
the patient to slightly hold their
breath and not to breathe in the
medication now after giving the oral
spray you'll want to make sure that the
patient doesn't rinse their mouth or eat
or drink anything for at least ten
minutes and you'll follow the same
protocol as you followed with the
sublingual tablet
by monitoring that blood pressure
constantly making sure it's within
parameters and monitoring their chest
pain and within five minutes you can
give a second dose and within five
minutes you can give a third dose and no
more than three doses okay so that is
how you give sublingual nitroglycerin
and oral spray thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos